herzlich willkommen noch nie gab es
innerhalb der kirchlichen hierarchie
eine derart starke opposition gegen
einen amtierenden papst jetzt gegen
franziskus das sagt der journalist und
vatikan insider
marco politi herzlich willkommen nach
rom herr politik
guten tag er hat politisch sie schreiben
ihren neuen buch kein papst der moderne
sei jesu fast gewesen wie franziskus wie
kommen sie zu dieser einsicht
es gibt schon seit jahren einen
bürgerkrieg einen untergrund bürgerkrieg
gegen den papst ist ein teil der kirche
ist eben sehr traditionell sehr
konservativ und kann diesen papst
überhaupt nicht leiden
es gibt leute die wollen den papst tod
das weißt ja papst selbst das hat der
papst einmal selbst gesagt ich weiß es
gibt priester die wollen dass ich tot
bin
vor ein paar jahren hat man einen
bischof für im zug höheren gesagt zu
seinem sekretär hoffen wir dass die
madonna es also so macht wie sie mit
johannes paul dem ersten gemacht hat und
wir wussten johannes paul der erste war
ja nur 30 tage papst diese opposition
hat natürlich ein paar große figuren
große persönlichkeiten die man kennt es
kann kardinal müller seien in
deutschland es kann
kardinal berg seien in den vereinigten
staaten oder kardinal sarah in der kurie
oder einen erzbischof vigano ehemaliger
botschafter des vatikans in washington
aber das ist nur die spitze des
eisberges es gibt schon einen großen
teil die kann diesen papst nicht leiden
und das sagen selbst anhänger des
papstes also kardinal kasper der
deutsche kardinal kasper hat gesagt es
gibt leute die wollen diesen papst nicht
es gibt leute die wollen dass dieser
papst womöglich schnell verschwindet
oder der oberst der jesuitenpater to
lose hat gesagt diese leute hoffen dass
der papst sich zurückzieht das wird ja
nicht tun aber sie wollen auch das
nächste konklave manipulieren
wir möchten wir müssen nicht vergessen
dass in den
letzten jahren es eine eskalation
gegeben hat gegen den papst bücher kamen
raus bücher von kardinal und von
bischöfen die nicht wollten dass er die
kommunion den wiederverheirateten
geschiedenen gibt es gab plakate es gab
einen falschen osservatore romano
es gab appelle die sagten ja ist ein
häretiker also ist eine eskalation die
andauert ja wir hören jetzt schon raus
da ist wirklich mächtig was am brodeln
gehen jedem langsam nach sie haben jetzt
schon viel aufgezählt ich möchte noch
mal ganz kurz in den oktober 19 gehen
und da sind es eben nicht nur diese
kirchenvertreter die sie eben gerade
genannt haben sondern insgesamt leute
die extrem viel hoffnung in die amazonas
synode und deshalb auch im franziskus
gesetzt haben laien die dann enttäuscht
wurden weil franziskus eben nicht die
lockerung des pflichtzölibats gewährt
hat man fragt sich da immer wieder hat
franziskus eigentlich unter druck
gehandelt und unter diesem druck den sie
gerade genannt haben
ganz bestimmt
franziskus wollte ja dass man in der
amazonas synode auch über die
möglichkeit von verheirateten priestern
spricht es kann in einer synode
passieren dass man ein thema anpackt
wenn es der papst nicht will der papst
selbst hatte gebilligt dass in dem ein
führungs dokumente der synode man über
dieses problem spricht und der papst
selbst hat als general referent dieser
synode den brasilianischen kardinal
claudio hummes ausgewählt der schon seit
jahrzehnten dafür ist dass man die
möglichkeit hat das auch verheiratete
männer priester sind also der anfang
dieser synode und auch die entwicklung
der synode entsprach dem was der papst
eigentlich wollte und will schon im
vorfeld der synode hat das eine hat es
eine starke opposition gegeben
es hat wieder einmal mit interviews und
mit appellen damit man nichts ändert und
wir müssen nicht vergessen dass gerade
am ende der synode als der papst daran
wahr sein dokument auszuarbeiten gab es
dieses buch von
dem emeritierten papst ratzinger und von
dem kardinal sarah wo man sagte
unbedingt soll man nichts an dem
kirchengesetz ändern
und da hat sich ganz bestimmt der papst
unter druck gefühlt natürlich sehr viele
leute in der kirche waren enttäuscht
aber ich hatte mich auch daran erinnert
was mir ein französischer kardinal sagt
eine große figur der nach konzils zeit
der kardinal etchegaray es inzwischen
gestorben und er sagte mir ja die ersten
die erste zeit mit franziskus wird so
sein wie er hat honigmond aber eines
tages werde er mit dem rücken an der
wand stehen und das ist eben nach
weihnachten mit franziskus passiert als
er sein dokument über die amazonas die
note geschrieben hat und nicht gebilligt
hat dass es verheiratete priester gibt
aber man muss auch auf die eine
raffinesse daran denken der papst hatte
ich gesagt dass er das nicht belegt oder
das ja das dokument zurück weiß der hat
gesagt dieses dokument liegt auf dem
tisch das bedeutet dass in jedem moment
dieser papst oder sein nachfolger sich
auf das dokument berufen kann ja sie
haben etwas wichtiges angesprochen
nämlich dieser konflikt der sich
entladen hat weil der emeritierte papst
benedikt der sechzehnte eben in dieser
zeit bevor franziskus seine
stellungnahme publiziert hat eine klare
stellungnahme für das zölibat
veröffentlicht hat eben daraus ist ein
konflikt entstanden man stellt sich
natürlich die frage was für ein
verhältnis haben denn die beiden
momentanen päpste zueinander ja lange
jahre lang war das verhältnis sehr gut
der papst franziskus hat auch gewollt
gleich nach seiner wahl er wusste es gab
eine enzyklika die ratzinger schon
praktisch zu ende geschrieben hat und
dort papst franziskus gesagt gut
publizieren wir zusammen dieser
enzyklika gerade um zu zeichnen um zu
zeigen dass er im besten verhältnis mit
ratzinger stand er hat immer gesagt
der emeritierte papst ist wie ein guter
großvater und von zeit zu zeit
gegner zu ihm sie sprachen miteinander
und man muss sagen
ratzinger war sehr korrekt lange jahre
entlang sehr korrekt auch wenn es leute
von der opposition zu ihm kamen
kardinäle oder bischöfe und die sagten
ja
man versteht nicht mehr was ich die
richtung der kirche
es sind so unordentliche zeiten und dort
immer ratzinger diese opposition diesen
versuch der opposition ihn zu
manipulieren abgewiesen und hat gesagt
der papst weiß was er tut der papst ist
franziskus und weshalb die hat man ernst
ist mit der amazonas synode hat es
diesen bruch gegeben und deswegen hat
man auch nach diesem buch von ratzinger
und kardinal sarah gab es eine große
diskussion im vatikan hat gesagt in
zukunft muss man wirklich denken wie
regelt man die position eines papstes
wenn er abgedankt es hat keinen sinn zu
sagen er ist ein emeritierter papst wird
staatssekretär kardinal parolin hat
gesagt es gibt nur einen papst das ist
der regierende papst
das hat benedikt auch immer wieder
betont trotzdem natürlich ist er in
seiner kleidung usw
weiterhin als emeritierter papst
sichtbar und offenkundig ist es so dass
genau an dieser zölibatsfrage sich das
entzündet hat wie sie das jetzt erklären
ja das ist die besonders heikle frage
ganz bestimmt es ist eine heikle frage
und wie gesagt man hat gesagt in zukunft
muss man auch wieder darüber nachdenken
wie wie ist der emeritierte papst
angezogen man soll überhaupt nicht
sprechen von einem emeritierten kann man
es sagen der papst abgedankt und er soll
mehr sein so wie ein mönch mit einer
mönchskutte aber man muss sagen wenn wir
wieder an diesem bürgerkrieg
diesen untergrundkrieg denken die
opposition hat es geschafft den papst zu
stoppen
und es gibt auch ein anderes feld wo die
opposition den papst bis jetzt gestoppt
hat und das ist die möglichkeit dass es
dass frauen zum diakonat gelangen denn
auch da hatte der papst sozusagen eine
öffnungs gäste gemacht vor ein paar
jahren hatte eine kommission einberufen
damit man so historisch über das
diakonat ja frauen nachdenkt aber diese
kommission war gespalten genauso wie die
kirche gespalten ist und ist zu keinem
resultat gekommen es hat ja papst eine
neue kommission einberufen aber niemand
weiß was wird der resultat dieser
kommission sein
sie schreiben ja ihr buch heißt das
franziskus komplott und das was jetzt
beschreiben ist offenbar ein komplott
sie sprechen sogar vom bürgerkrieg
also wer betreibt denn dieses komplott
ganz genau und vor allen dingen was mich
wundert das klingt so spezifisch
intendiert das ist nicht einfach so
geschehen sondern ist es ist ein
komplott gegen den papst und zwar ein
bewusstes dieses komplott wie gesagt ist
im gange seit jahren und so etwas hatte
zum beispiel nicht gegeben zu den zeiten
von johannes paul des zweiten da gab es
natürlich große diskussionen zum
beispiel über abtreibung oder auch über
die kommunion für die
wiederverheirateten geschiedenen
da gab es auch sehr große kritiker gegen
johannes baut den zweiten denken ja zum
beispiel auch an den theologen hans küng
aber es gab nicht so ein versuch den
papst zu delegitimieren das ist das neue
und vor allem wie es auch der
jesuitenpater spadaro gesagt das ist der
chefredakteur der wichtigen jesuiten
zeitschrift die villa cattolica er hat
gesagt das ist kein hübsches pontifikat
das ist ein dramatisches pontifikat wo
es kardinäle gibt die sind gegen den
papst und atheisten die den papst
verteidigen und jack tischen historiker
andrea riccardi hat gesagt in den
letzten 100 jahren hat es nie so eine
opposition gegen
vom gegen den papst von seiten des
klerus und von seiten der bischöfe da
müssen wir denken es gibt einen großen
teil in der kirche wir können sagen 30
unter dem klerus und unter den bischöfen
die sagen nichts offen gegen den papst
aber die rudern gegen den papst also sie
sie unterstützen nicht den papst und
dann versuchen sie ihn zu stoppen wie
gesagt auf wichtigen feldern wie die wie
das frauen diakon oder wie die
möglichkeit dass es verheiratete
priester
ich möchte dass ein bisschen besser
verstehen ganz kurz ist diese position
denn primär theologisch begründet oder
sind das andere gründe der soziologe
frederik macht etwas spricht auch von
seilschaften die man eben bewusst
schützen möchte und auf dieser basis
natürlich gewisse positionen entstehen
frederik mattel hat ein sehr schönes
buch geschrieben über die homosexuellen
über die homosexuellen seilschaften aber
die betreiben nicht so eine eine politik
das ist etwas ganz was anders das sind
dann das sind dann leute die die wollen
ihr eigenes revier schützen
die opposition ist einesteils eine
theologische opposition die sind eben
einfach nicht einverstanden dass der
papst zum beispiel von einer großen
barmherzigkeit der kirche spricht oder
von einem warmherzigen antlitz des
gottes dass der papst nicht immer nur
auf die normen schaut dass der papst
eben sagt wer bin ich um urteil zu
fällen über einen homosexuellen sie sind
dagegen dass der papst zb einen
spanischen transsexuellen im vatikan
empfangen hat mit seinem bischof und mit
seiner verlobten
sie sind dagegen wenn der papst anfängt
zb auch in führungspositionen in der
römischen kurie frauen zu bringen es gab
in der letzten zeit verschiedene
nominierungen wo frauen und das
sekretäre in den dikasterien des
vatikans geworden sind aber neben dieser
theologischen opposition gibt es auch
eine opposition von
von klerikern und von bischöfen die
haben angst dass die kirche zu
demokratisiert wird das ist eine dass es
eine protestant easy rung der
katholischen kirche gibt das ist
natürlich eine rationelle angst aber in
einem so großen gefühle wie die
katholische kirche mehr als 1 milliarde
und 300 millionen gibt es eben auch
psychologische opposition aber
gleichzeitig gibt es auch eine
sozialökonomische opposition außerhalb
der kirche in dieser papst stört
ökonomische kreise wenn er vom
naturschutz spricht wenn er in seiner
entwicklung laudator sie sagt der natur
verfall bringt auch zu einem sozialen
verfall und wenn man die naturressourcen
ruiniert dann ruiniert man auch das
gefüge der gesellschaften oder wenn der
papst so spricht von der ungleichheit
und sagt diese ungleichheit ist nicht
möglich kann man nicht mehr tolerieren
dann gibt es eben industriegruppen
ökonomische gruppen auch politische
rechtsgerichtete gruppen die wollen
nichts von einem sogenannten kommunisten
papst hören genau bei der papst immer
sagt ich sag genau dasselbe was es im
evangelium gibt oder was johannes paul
der zweite gesagt hat genau das mit den
kommunisten papst ist natürlich eines
der der dinge die man ihm vorwirft immer
wieder
ich möchte trotzdem das noch mal kurz
hervorholen was sie ganz zu beginn
gesagt haben sie haben nämlich so
aufgezählt welche personen relevant sind
für diese opposition gegen den papst und
das sind in der regel die meisten sind
ältere bereits emeritierte kardinäle
stellt sich die frage sind die wirklich
so einflussreich wie das was jetzt
gerade zeichnen
auch der soziologe marco marzano sagt
die sind eigentlich vernachlässigbar und
sogar noch mehr sie dienen franziskus
dazu seinen reformkurs nicht durchziehen
zu müssen
ich glaube das weiß man sehr gut von der
politik auch ein älterer politiker hat
in seinem leben eine seilschaft
entwickelt von anhängern und auch von
leuten die
seine ideen vertreten also auch wenn man
sagt zum beispiel kardinal meisner ist
in deutschland schon gestorben oder
kardinal kaffee ist in italien
gesprochen
das sind zwei von den vier kardinälen
die ein sehr kritisches dokument
gegenpapst franziskus geschrieben haben
nach den familien synoden als der papst
autorisiert hat dass es die kommunion
gibt für die wiederverheirateten
geschiedenen aber eben diese personen ob
sie nun als sind ob sie nun emeritiert
sind oder ob sie nun vielleicht noch in
der römischen kurie arbeiten wie zb
kardinal sarah sind einflussreiche leute
die hinter sich eine zahl von anhängern
haben und diese anhänger sind in der
zwischenzeit bischöfe geworden kardinäle
geworden oder sind gut vertreten in
laienorganisation oder in anderen
organisationen also sagen wir so
universitäten oder ein hilfswerken das
ist dann sozusagen eine eine opposition
von gleich denkenden leuten und es ist
wie gesagt die spitze eines eisberges
und wenn es dann dazu kommt dass man
sich zählen muss wir haben es ganz klar
gesehen in der familien synode
jeder jeder weiß in den kongo oder in
den synoden muss man einen
mehrheitsbeschluss mit einer zwei
drittel mehrheit haben und in den beiden
familien sie noten gab es keine
zweidrittelmehrheit um klar zu sagen ja
wir sind dafür dass die kommunion auch
den wiederverheirateten geschiedenen
gegeben wird es gab diese
zweidrittelmehrheit nicht also gab es
mehr als ein drittel leute die waren
dagegen die haben das blockiert und dann
musste sozusagen der papst in seinem
dokument eine hintertür öffnen mit einer
kleinen fußnote wo man von den
sakramenten sprach aber wenn es dazu
kommt dass man sozusagen die stimmen
zählen muss dann sieht man dass diese
opposition eben mehr als ein drittel
stark ist in der kirche und 30 35
prozent auch im politischen leben ist
sehr wichtig sie sprechen jetzt gerade
mit die von dieser hintertür in dem
dokument ein ein teil seiner methode ist
ja auch dieser zick-zack-kurs der wird
ihm ja genau auch von den konservativen
aber eben auch von den eher liberalen
vorgeworfen man wünscht sich klare worte
von beiden seiten
was hat er denn eigentlich an reformen
wirklich erreicht franziskus es gibt
sehr viele sachen wo der papst schon
änderung gebracht hat sehr konkrete
änderungen also hat angefangen mit der
kuh der reform
dies war noch nicht zu ende aber die
kurie straffer gemacht also es gibt da
weniger kardinäle in zukunft es gibt
laien die in führungspositionen
gestiegen sind zum ersten mal gibt es
ein laie der ist chef eines dikasterien
es das ist das kommunikations
dikasterien er hat frauen in
führungspositionen gebracht in der
römischen kurie
er hat die bank gesäubert wir wissen die
die vatikanbank ior war jahrzehntelang
ein dunkles geschäft da wurden mafia
gelder reingewaschen da wurden gelder
für italienische parteien geschleuste
durch die vatikanbank und der papst hat
autorisiert das
mehr als 24.000 konten durchleuchtet
wurden von einer unabhängigen
organisation die in london ist
promontory group das hat keine
staatsbank der welt autorisiert eine
andere gruppe in alle computers
hineinzuschauen und mehr als 2000
konnten sind geschlossen worden
es gibt jetzt ein anti geldwäsche
komitee in dem vatikan und vor allem was
ist sehr wichtig es ist nicht mehr
möglich dass leute die nichts mitte
vatikan oder mit religiösen organisation
zu tun haben jetzt ein konto in der
vatikanbank haben und vor allem jetzt
gibt es eine kooperation zwischen dem
vatikan und den staatlichen
justizbehörden der anderen länder da
sind verträge unterschrieben worden mit
deutschland mit amerika mit vielen
anderen ländern
jetzt gibt es eine kooperation gegen
finanzverbrechen das hat es vorher nicht
gegeben ein anderer konkreter punkt
gerade in den in den letzten monaten des
jahres 2009 10 gibt es endlich ein
dokument das zeigt ganz klar die
prozedur wie kann man einem kardinal
einem patriarchen einen bischof den
prozess machen
der entfernt da persönlich
verantwortlich ist für einen missbrauch
oder der einen missbrauch versteckt hat
wir wissen das ist das ganz große
problem der kirche jahrzehntelang und
jahrhundertelang jetzt gibt es endlich
eine klare prozedur wie kann man einem
bischof und einem kardinal den prozess
machen und ein anderes dokument öffnet
die archive über die prozesse oder über
die information über priester die
missbrauch begangen haben und diese
transparenz der archive kann auch der
weltlichen justiz zu gute kommen das
sind ganz konkrete änderungen ich habe
eine letzte kurze frage an sie selbst
wenn es sehr interessant ist was sie
erzählen in ihrem buch schreiben eben
auch von der schlussphase des
pontifikats und dass es noch einige
überraschungen bereithalten würde
woran der
sie da konkret ein beispiel der papst
will dass die kirche demokratisiert wird
in diesem sinn dass die synoden also die
parlamente wo die vertreter der bischöfe
der ganzen welt viel mehr
mitspracherecht haben dass die kirche
regiert wird nicht nur vom papst allein
sondern von den bischöfen in der ganzen
welt ganz herzlichen dank herr politi
nach rom
mit dieser sendung verabschiede ich mich
in die sommerpause
in den kommenden wochen zeigen wir ihnen
ein best-of sternstunde religion der
letzten monate in der zwischenzeit
finden sie mich auf twitter und
instagram und hier geht es jetzt weiter
mit dem philosophen stammtisch in der
frage ob den generationenvertrag eine
zukunft hat machen sie es gut bis dann
[Musik]